take a look at this chart it's the S&P
500 on Wednesday March 18th when the
index plunged more than seven percent
triggering something called a circuit
breaker you can see it right here at
12:56 p.m. trading was halted for a full
15 minutes it was the fourth circuit
breaker in less than two weeks as
markets went haywire on fears that the
coronavirus would cause a global
economic meltdown circuit breakers
halted trading on March 9th 12th and
16th as well circuit breakers were
created to mitigate crashes but some
traders say they're ineffective and in
fact they may serve to make a bad day
even worse we'll explain but first
here's how they work
circuit breakers were created in the
aftermath of a 1987 stock market crash
known as Black Monday on October 19 1987
we had a big crash with the Dow Jones
fell approximately 25% during the day
and it was a mess the printers were
jamming in the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange it couldn't print the
order tickets fast enough nobody really
knew what their position was they
realized the market could not handle
volume the purpose of circuit breakers
was so markets could handle the increase
in trading that happened during sudden
major down swings a circuit breaker is a
stop in trading the idea behind a
circuit breaker is that something's gone
wrong so you need time to assess the
problem and think about the impact when
the S&P 500 drops seven percent from the
previous close a message goes out and
noun Seng the trading halt at this
moment all the exchanges will stop
accepting new orders under current rules
there are three levels of circuit
breakers they're triggered if the S&P
drops 7% 13% and 20% in a single session
before last week the lowest circuit
breaker which was then at 10% had only
been tripped once the level 2 and level
3 circuit breakers have never been
triggered on October 27 1997 the Asian
financial crisis in the United States
the Hong Kong
market had crashed the night before and
the route hit New York so that was the
only time the old 10% market wide
circuit breaker was triggered on May 6
2010 the flash crash happened this was a
very strange event where the Dow Jones
Industrial Average fell nearly a
thousand points around nine point two
percent at the time and then bounced
back just as quickly for reasons that
are still a matter of the day in
response the SEC changed the percentage
move required for a circuit breaker to
trigger from 10 percent to 7 percent the
SEC also switched the index that would
determine the circuit breaker up until
that point it had been the Dow Jones
Industrial Average not the S&P 500 but
some traders question the value of
halting the stock market even during a
crash proponents of circuit breakers say
they do what they're meant to do they
give people a chance to breathe and
pause and think about what's happening
in the markets that they can come back
in and maybe buy something so solid
critics of circuit breakers say that
sometimes they actually exacerbate
volatility and they sell up worse the
reason for that is because you could
have investors who see that we're
getting close to circuit-breaker levels
and they sell immediately because
they're worried about getting caught in
the circuit breaker not doing all the
things that their position you know we
are definitely in a situation that most
of us have not seen before and we don't
know what's gonna happen
circuit breakers are a sign of extreme
times as long as the current of virus
continues to frankly kill people and
cause a very sharp economic slowdown I
want to surprise more circuit breakers
happen